hey i'm hungry in game or in real life
oh hey okay um oh you have your mayor
top hat that's why we did the mayor
thing
yeah and then amy got me a real top hat
oh that yeah that's good um okay
organizational system probably still
all kinds of screwing oh yeah
frick all my uh flowers for the honey i
gotta get a scarecrow
oh right we gotta get we gotta get an
island so we can get the honey
that's right i have now played another
game with another group where we
surpassed where we are right now so i
can't remember
what the hell is happening to save my
life you
have other people you stream with i have
other people i like
more than you equal similarly to you
where is skype oh no heads and whatever
oh god
over here oh it's actually called scrap
now holy lord i mean i think that was
called scrap before
but hurt my feelings why don't you i
mean your system
is mind-blowingly brilliant mark thank
you
the elbows and knees but we still have
heads heads there's actually heads and
heads heads make sense don't mock heads
don't mock heads why is there feathers
and heads
uh well this could grow on heads holy
[ __ ] we have to keep watering this grass
or something don't we because we don't
have an automated sprinkler
yeah we got a water the grass sorry what
an egg
we got an egg oh hell yeah oh yeah we
have a turkey i forgot
oh yeah we can shear i mean milk the
goat
milk the goat yeah milk the goat
something is being
something where is that that's uh
probably my scarecrow
oh nope it's eaten it's eating these
vegetables oh i forgot i had these
vegetables right these are compostables
oh wait i learned a thing mark the heads
the heads have value do they if you put
the head into the biofuel thing
it almost fills it up ooh no cash hey
why does this say mark sucks
xd i don't know that must be that thing
wade did you capping me
you giving me cap how do you okay no cap
no character
i don't know the full usage of that yet
is it like
he he caps they cap it who
he she
[Music]
is yeah captain you dear kappas me
yeah i'm gonna put one shark head
and we're gonna have so many biofuels
capramus
boom oh we don't have honey that's the
problem that probably is like
we do have honey and there's honey uh
there was no honey in the thing
it wasn't making the fuel gotcha yeah we
got a
32 honeycomb right now that's enough to
make a fair amount of honey actually
yeah we just need the glass and the um
other stuff we got oh island off to the
right
it's tiny but it'll have something we
have like
i should be cooking sand then is what
you're saying uh we have
coke coke bowls cookables i'm gonna make
i'll i'll grind out the i'll grind out
the glass then
yeah um who wants to oh am i the captain
man
you're low on food right now yeah that's
a
matter of opinion
wow calm down uh we are leaving this
island
i agree that is factually accurate um or
mark mark with this bottle
why you want this bot folder i have one
well no no it's not a drinking bottle
it's a candle bomb
too late what does that mean i don't
know it's too late man
it's too late bottles are over all right
20 20 also canceled bottle oh wait we
need to get this recipe
can we can we go to the right like a tad
no
swim for it you better swim you gotta go
now
i'm gonna die no you're not no you're
not he's not
we got your back don't even worry we got
your back oh
come on no you're fine what do you want
oh shark is behind you better hurry
oh that oh you hate to see that
see you were totally so scared you were
like
one hundred percent fine baby there was
an island off to the left as well
we're missing some of these uh well
captain i'm sorry i don't mean to
question it but uh some of these
are you saying that we should go to an
island is that why i'm just saying
eventually
we might need to you can you can input
your opinion that's okay that's okay
we're all we're all on the same ship
here
captain wade sneezes very annoyingly i
want to do something about that
i wanted to take a moment cause i
thought it was one of those like
explosive sneezes that made a mess
thankfully it was not
oh that's a tiny shitty island no we go
to a big island that's where we're going
big island there's some okay
you saw a shitty island what there's
something weird to the right is that
another small island
oh yeah that looks a little bigger yeah
hey to the right bob there's a slightly
bigger island i think it's what you're
looking for
captain oh i uh i
i'm ready what what do the kids say
that's it you got it they say i captain
he just asked if they're right
i'm ready
[Laughter]
it looks like there's stuff on that
island okay it seems likely
how do we make shark bait because i'm
starting to realize oh it needs
specific types of fish is for sure
if we actually did that though we would
be in good shape right i mean we have
good weapons we could just
kill the [ __ ] out of it well but that's
so it's
moon
uh do we have clay anywhere is clay a
lump uh no that's in
post post uh that's an ingots
uh because uh post oh we're about to hit
this bad boy
no what that's not clay we're about to
hit oh clay
oh i don't know it's supposed to yeah he
thought you said clay not clay
no i don't know that's weird all right
we're here we sort of
slammed right into it that's fine yeah
well it's all right
[Music]
oh my god he begaws when he lays eggs
nice
he the chicken man who's laying the eggs
what do you mean
all right you're right i'm sorry i need
the net the swift net i forgot the swift
net that's how i catch the bees
yeah we need well we need flowers more
than we need bees
the bees will come if we can get the
flowers that is true
if we seed them they will come okay well
this is clearly a flower and it's not
letting me get it but whatever
you know whoa oh my god there's a pig
that's pretty dramatic
i think they're all enemy pigs i don't
think there's such thing as a non-enemy
pig
why did i get whoa the bees stung me
this time this never stung me
bees stun me they've never done that
they've always did you hey there's
another chickypoo
hey chicky friend no one's paying
attention to you what no
i know oh i can go get the metal
detector maybe there's like a metal over
here
oh maybe i wonder if that's a thing let
me go get that let me check it out
let me see what is up got every time i
see this majestic tower of yours bob i
get like
like a tingly feeling is incredible it's
beautiful right
it is all right oh we do have a reading
anyone got a shovel no sir we have a
tools chest
escape chest has the shovel i heard
yep got it right here in my hand i think
it's the one that used to be labeled
marquee poopoo
i don't think it was enabled that at all
yeah it's now called
tools i don't know
that's the one yep yeah got that one
i got it it's near the clay chip not the
clay chest but the clay chest
yep i've got a safe here
thanks man okay go for it really let's
see
glass explosive powder leather yeah oh
three titanium oh yeah we've got three
titanium ingots already there's
something that needed titanium
i forget what it was though is this um
is this where you dug is that what this
dirt mound is there's not actual dirt
here to dirt
to dig up right no it's i just you saw
me do that
i was yeah
okay hey guys there's buffer fisher on
this island right here oh get him get
him get him get him
he already exploded so way way past that
where's the shark at i don't care i'm
going down oh there's another do we need
another
chicken bird i said that a while ago but
yeah we probably
if whatever we can capture we probably
should because so we have all the okay
although chickens basically only give
you eggs
which are good they're food right no
they're mainly used for healing saddles
oh what why you can't make an omelette
with them but their their primary value
is i think healing style why would that
be their pro we just die and then come
back
resurrection is a thing but if you die
and come back you lose all the stuff you
had
well then don't die in an inconvenient
place
no no you can't get it you lose it well
then
one of us will pick us up and then this
is so clear
yeah that's always worked out really
well
we're gonna get more puffer fish to
craft more ammo for this
net gun i don't have any ammo at the
moment that's uh oh we don't have any i
thought we had some can you just pick up
the chicken i thought you could just
pick it up you have to net it
once you net it you can pick it up it
becomes like friendly
really stupid tell me more about how
proximity voice is so
obvious oh how that shark broke my
machete
broke his broke your machete on his face
he's dead the shark is dead
yeah cook him and eat him and become his
power
put his head in the biofuels put his
head in our gas tank and burn it for
fun burn his head we're getting really
violent yeah what happened to our
humanity did we ever have it
man we live on a flock of garbage what
do you mean humanity
i thought we left it with you mark what
is garbage anyway who defines what
garbage is
me and this is garbage we live on
garbage it's garbage fair enough captain
you dare defy my definition you would
never get inside this box i've made for
you and shut up
me what happens if i just dive down into
the abyss
isn't that is that bad ah well define it
i find the bottom of the ocean
yep i'm gonna go just go down forever
actually
well that's what i thought near that
other part of the ocean on that island
and it just kept going down
and down and yep i'm over halfway around
chunk didn't we have never-ending
amounts of stone at one point
stoner what you talking about yeah we
got a stoner first
section here first there's a stoner
section sorry course
of course it was my mistake i know
it's my fault okay oh my god diving deep
into the ocean apparently makes me go
far
far away from the island what the hell
are you still diving
wait what did i just enter the zone
what's happening i'm having a seizure
welcome to this this is this is zone
bob is in the zone did i just teleport
this is a different island i swear to
god this is a different island are you
guys here no you're here okay okay it's
fine everything's fine calm down shut up
all right all right all right shut up
there were no flowers on that so
unfortunately honey's going to be a
little low but we
do have plenty of wood to load into the
react
to the engines we have enough honeycomb
to make a few more honeys and we have a
few
we can just go to another island yeah
we're fine for biofuel we're fine
i'm putting the eggs in the eat me chest
despite my reservations about doing so
no no they're going the other one what
other one
the cooking one the food one oh yeah
that one needs for the the the cooking
okay cook me got it yeah cook me eat me
i mean could you eat a raw egg i'm
pretty sure you probably could
but in real life i don't think you can
in this game
when i was a boy i ate eight dozen eggs
now i only eat 14.
something that was it dude nailed it are
you what is that
gaston caster is that that dude
gaston from the the disney movie
whatever that beauty and the princess
all right what is it do we have another
heading for another island that we need
to get to uh
to the garneal to the gurnel
0373 have we done that heading before i
don't think so
uh tangaroa caravan town
we did that downtown was the last one we
did i think 10 year old is the next one
kangaroo definitely next run 0.373
my dudes okay let me turn this on okay
how many disc travel units are we away
from there we're 1808 away
it is when i'm looking at this thing now
i don't know what that translates to
on your thing it's to north
west nor northwest based on what
the i don't know how this point
we're yeah let me
so from the for from the orientation of
the ship itself
what does that even mean because we
drive forward what do you mean what does
that mean but why is forward to the
right
degrees to the left i got this okay so
all right engineering be prepared
captain on the helm
cabin on the helm can we get anchor up
please anchor
up please anchor
up and on my mark engage the engineers
are you ready wait come on we gotta do
this in sync
with the other the other injury
one mark that was good good sync
beautiful navigation heading check
please
navigation heading check please
navigation is
probably good so the right the the like
easterly line on there should be
pointed towards the heading why don't we
turn the heading
to where that would be pointing because
shut up
i'm turning off the heading okay was it
good
i want to check him no it was good don't
look no it's fine
what are you looking for i'm starving to
death the heading is pretty good but i
could be better it could be better
okay could be better could be better
could be better i'm gonna move these
sales
discovered we don't need them i mean we
could use the sales
i thought we confirmed that they didn't
stack did we confirm that
oh yeah they definitely don't make us go
any faster or anything but i mean i
guess aesthetically it looks nice
yeah a fleet of sails what's wrong with
that well i'll just have one
i don't think i can pick up this radio
station
what are all these wires whoa remember
it's a radio station and three
antennae why did you point it this way i
you made it
i didn't i don't know who you're being
outraged at
but you made this i didn't make it 100
you i do not remember that so i don't
think it is true
there's another island on route that is
not our island we're still 1500 away
but we could stop for flowers it looks
very lush ooh
we certainly could stop i mean we need
flowers for honey eventually but we are
good on biofuel like if we just swing by
i can
jump off grab them and get out of there
all right
i just made 12 honeys so we're actually
pretty rich
never mind we're fine we didn't get any
puffer fish though right
oh yeah oh my god we're gonna crash into
this island all right we should go to
this island
look there's like a crash
oh my god what is that that's pretty
sick actually
oh hello dead seagull how does it feel
to be a dumb piece of [ __ ] bird
[Laughter]
thought so red berries what the hell are
red berries used for
we had berries before sure sure i've had
a berry
yeah i know i know about berries plenty
of flowers on this island i'm getting a
good amount
oh this is oh oh this is a crash play
and i
that is what that is i thought it was
wrong
bob i got a present for you uh from for
a little old me
yeah bob i got a present for you i'm
gonna come back with it am i gonna like
it or am i gonna not love
this present i can guarantee you're
gonna love this present i got this one
especially for you
where are you there you are okay i'm
coming i'm at the cooking station and
i'll wait i'll wait to receive my
presents all right
here it comes
you're going to love that oh wow that's
a good present
looks good that's a good presence and
that that's a pretty good look that's
good look at that
look at it well i'm looking at it look
at it
i am you're just captain awesome now
yeah i told you that's what i think i
agree yeah
anyway i got a lot of flowers um i'm
gonna plant them down wait did you pick
any more uh flower seeds
could you get any of those i did not
pick any flowers do i need to start
grabbing those
uh no i mean if you got if there were
any flowers if you could grab them but
it's okay if you didn't
i didn't notice it on the way up i only
noticed the berries i think you might
have grabbed them but i'll take another
peek uh
yeah just give it a gander but if not
it's fine where is two year olds
[Music]
what are twitters tools bro
oh trolls hey the bees are back
seeds specifically do you have to just
get lucky yeah when you pick the flowers
you know sometimes you get seeds
sometimes you [ __ ] ass
is there anything we need from under the
water around this island poofers
oh i did i got uh one red seed nice
where are we putting those
that's that's stuff we need you just
well maybe don't plant them yet i'll put
them in the seed next to the honey
put them in the yeah the bee business um
are we just tossing red flowers are we
keeping those somewhere
there's a happy uh chest anything that
makes you happy
uh will go in there which is flowers so
and the one i'm looking at right now is
is the one you would want
the one on the left yeah i see okay you
know what mark i'm going to respect your
organizational system
thank you oh oh oh oh oh no no not the
one here nothing else oh did he actually
get
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no it's fine
it's fine it's going for the nest you
know our very valuable nest that
definitely gets a lot sure
for sure sure almost got that that would
have been risky
i don't know if risky is the right word
but would have been risky
they just [ __ ] them out hey [ __ ]
the most horrendously inappropriate
children's game i've ever seen in my
life
all right well is there anything of
value in the water i think this island's
pretty well
tapped uh no our bees are back in
business which is good
um other than that i don't know oh
there's not even a corpse in this downed
plane
well i mean i pulled the helmet off of
that so i'm assuming the corpse
decomposed around it also what an idiot
he like
it's nothing but ocean around he hits
the one island
you know what i mean yeah and uh in a
plane that floats he's going down and
he's like ah
aim for the land if you guys know what
mr bucket is it was a child's toy
that came out i don't explain it anymore
yeah it was literally deployed
in his mouth it was a little
battery-powered bucket who would like
spit balls out of his mouth and you'd
like scoop up your color so like four
different colored balls
so you'd have like yellow red green blue
and you would race to get your balls in
mr bucket before he'd spit your balls
back out
yeah whoever will make sure you know you
say don't explain it and then he just
keeps explaining it
i can't believe it well i wanted people
to know what mr bucket was
yeah well maybe they weren't ready to
know you ever think about that
well then sometimes you just gotta throw
them in the deep end and see if they
survive well did they
did they no they are dead but honestly
survival of the fittest at this point
that's true i always i always believe in
that live long enough to see yourself
become the villain
or you don't yep classic all right
engineering can we get some engines
engines
i'm hungry oh you you know me
also not taking care of my body okay
anchor up
it's up already never mind anchor down
anchor now
up engine
what oh [ __ ] did you metal detector that
island oh
[ __ ] it's fine it's probably good call
good call fine
you know i'm gonna make a bucket i'm
gonna milk this goat
and i'm gonna i'm gonna milk the [ __ ]
out of this goat
give me your milk give i picked up the
goat
who's attacking my uh how do i put down
get the
thank you how do i put it down how do i
put how do i put it down
no no panic
don't get book it i get it i got a
bucket of milk
whoo nice no no
[Laughter]
are you spilling your bucket of milk or
something what's going on it's fine
don't worry about it
[Music]
you guys i look i don't want to redo our
whole farming system but i learned some
stuff about farms that blew my mind
recently
what oh yeah okay you can hang the
farming
the the crop plots on walls
so you can on two vertical walls you can
have like
a like a dozen crop plots how does that
work how does dirt not fall out of it
it's about it's a wooden box it's a
fully enclosed
it's a i don't know man oh it hangs him
vertically oh it's like it's
mounted on the wall yeah okay that makes
more sense i also pictured them sitting
there sideways
like the bottom of the planter is flat
against the wall
i mean that's what that's what it i mean
i just
that's on me more eggs geez these things
really
[ __ ] them out no not you get down
beelzebub elizabeth get down
elizabeth how many buckets of milk do we
need i don't know what what if we even
use it for
baked goods oh no er head broth fish
stew
i guess dude head broth
man thank goodness this fishing thing
don't move no head broth
break a skateboard what
what did you just say
a meme that's like 80 percent the video
uh as described by wade what
i say that all the time there's a kid
who's on a cell phone
and he's like so no head and then like
he throws his phone and
snaps his skateboard into what that's
just that's just the vine that's
it it's a meme mark i have not seen this
one
you know about the memes that the
children do if it ain't on
tick tock i don't know about it it's on
pre-tic talk
what is this there's just somebody
requesting this dude on his cell phone
presumably his girlfriend is like no
head and gets all pissed off and breaks
his skateboard
i almost called it prick talk but that's
not a good name for it
tic tocs is crazy tik tok is
surprisingly entertaining i've learned
so much good cooking knowledge from tick
tock
oh that's a good point yeah cooking
cooking tick tock
is dope yeah like all the privacy
whatever's aside like there's
good content on tick tock privacy
whatever
shut up cry babies yeah bunch of crap
what do you
not want your information publicly
shared were you some kind of idiot
who is out here cooking all these fish
that are useful for stuff
new new rule new rule please do not cook
tilapia or no palm frits or herrings i
guess you're cooking mostly tilapia
do not cook palm frits or herrings palm
prince herring's no cook
got it pomfrets and herrings are useful
because that's what you need to make
shark bait
don't cook oh okay i'm gonna put the
palm fritted
whatever herring down into the happy
bucket because they're kind of smart
they're happy they're not
dying right now they won't be happy
later but for now they apply to the
happy
wobbly people oh my god what in the hell
is ahead of us
oh jesus that's the thing
is that's the thing what is that that's
a dome
that reminds me of my bald head this i
believe is currently the last
part of the story of this game is that
well we're done with raft again all
right that was quick let's come back all
right let's
we don't need to explore let's get out
of here all right sounds good guys
hey take a raid shadow legends
brought to you take a break take a
rainshot of legends everyone
30 000 silver and an epic champion an
epic
champion you won't get addicted at all
look afk arena is where it's really at
no no no no no you
that's not funny i'm not laughing good
then keep laughing
no i'm not i'm not laughing oh look at
you
where do we go into this oh there's
arrows on the bottom
wow those are convenient that is um this
is a
this is a thing it's real big
a boss why not i need to turn
oh you have a good point sir
oh no we're gonna crash what the hell oh
i was scared she got so scared he
sneezed
oh man
oh god i ate a raw potato i'm an idiot
all right well
yeah i've been eating raw beets i've
just been living off of them pretty much
oh it is a domed city
oh i didn't even look we got close
enough to see what's inside yeah
i mean it looks lovely in there to be
perfectly honest
even if it's a great game is it this
door
no the arrows continue there's got to be
like a dock or something
well that's an emergency exit why would
there be an emergency exit where would
you
where are they going to go to the ocean
and pray what kind of an emergency could
a domed in city have
why does it even need to be a dome
anyway what's the point of the dome it's
just gonna get hot in there
it keeps the sickness out what's sick
are we
sick yeah this is actually a zombie game
what
yeah it was you the whole time oh i see
the dock it's oh yeah
all right here i'm gonna walk
ramming speed my dudes okay i think the
tower ain't gonna make this one boss
no no no no we go in here we'll go in
here i think the buck teeth are gonna
shear the roof right off
we win these we win these we win these
we win these we
win our construction is sturdy this will
hold up oh
[Music]
cliffhanger
bye